we want nebraska to be recognized as a
basketball state
within the next few years south sudanese
players are going to infiltrate the game
massively and i want omaha to be the
center of that because this is where the
community is
my name is juan deloni i am the founder
and executive director of the omaha
talents academy
we are a vassal program dedicated
towards serving the south sudanese
population
omaha is the largest population of south
sudanese outside of africa
from the moment that i picked up a ball
it was something that i knew i wanted to
do and i wanted to get better at
when i got the chance to become the
player that i was and ending up in a
division one school and realizing that
hey you know i know guys that are just
as good that are just as capable we're
built to play this game you know the
only thing that's really missing is it's
the training
this is where it all started
a few kids wanted to get some basketball
lessons and right here
you know right here on this concrete is
where we would work on our stuff
we started this program in 2012. four
years later these guys are incredible
players i'm probably spending more time
on the phone with high level division
one coaches than i ever had at any point
in my life
egweck has been probably one of the best
players in the state since seventh grade
the community has wrapped his arms
around them and we want to see a great
do well
i started with the omaha talents when i
was in middle school i was gary player
of the year for state of nebraska in
2016.
i just think a lot about basketball and
all the fortune i've had with it
i was born in south sudan i came over to
the united states when i was four
we come from
a journey that's really really really
painful
a lot of us were born in refugee camps
it almost felt like the world is not
designed for us
we've been on the run for as long as i
can remember trying to find a home one
country after another
i grew up in the south omaha projects
i came here at nine years old it made us
men it gave us enough challenges by the
time that we're 18 20 years old we're
ready to take on the world
most people look at this thing here you
know and they they see a clothes hanger
this was actually our first basket i
remember being
yay high you know and grabbing the ball
and trying to dunk on each other
basketball has created a really really
really special brotherhood it brings a
lot of joy in my heart to see all these
other sudanese kids just really making
something out of nothing because when we
first came we really didn't have
anything
i'm really excited i think omar should
be exciting i think the basketball world
should be really really excited about
what's going to be coming we can see it
very clearly you know it's just a matter
of time when working
[Music]
you